how many guys here are familiar with
crisper cast n who's familiar with
crisper it's Gene altering technology
gen altering technology little creepy so
Vinnie are you following the story
closely Brandon Brandon hook me up okay
so check this out imagine if in 2012
this lady from UC Berkeley comes up with
this concept called uh crisp uh cast 9
okay crisper cast 9 2013 crisper gets
started this company 2016 they go public
their stock goes all the way up to
nearly $200 today it's like a $4 half
billion a company when was the date that
they just got there on December 8th uh
FDA approved the first crisper treatment
sickle cell disease what this Gene
editing does you can literally imagine
going to the doctor you and your wife
and you say
doc doc ask you question Vinnie how tall
would you guys like your son to be um 64
okay great boom uh what color eyes would
you want your son to have blue yeah okay
great um what color hair would you want
your son to have blonde great you
literally order what you want your kid
to have and they put those genes by
editing it for you to have exactly the
baby you want to have now you may say p
there's no way that's possible how long
ago was it where people started deciding
how many people would say you know what
I don't want to have three different
pregnancies doc can we do one pregnancy
three kids if you had money you would go
in and say what let's have triplets how
long has that been going on top 20 years
with the um uh invitro fertilization but
watch this guys and they can plant
multiple 20 years is not a long time
you're manipulating having more kids so
these guys sat there and said if we can
manipulate that what if we can
manipulate the exact type of a kid you
can have now here's the thing they
tested on a couple hundred people they
tested lymphoma so this Gene Ting can
actually do some good which is cancer
cure AIDS cure a lot of different things
but when you think about Gene editing
Charlie what's the first thing you think
about with this invention of crisper
cast n yeah mean I think of eugenics
first and foremost um and I mean I first
of all I don't trust the technology and
then who's going to be in charge of it
look the only possible hope is that
potentially there are some people that
are born with some really really
unfortunate stuff okay really
unfortunate stuff that if we could find
some way to limit that or eliminate it
praise God what I mean I mean um someone
who's boring with MLS right luk
Garrick's disease right that that
there's a way get rid of it but look um
this is this is going in a direction
that I think is very dangerous almost
End Time stuff for those of us that
follow the Bible where this is not about
correcting this is about designing this
is about taking a role of God and trying
to design the human being you want I'm
sorry I'm not on board for it right
absent an intervention that could save
somebody's life from a life-threatening
ill for example if there are two parents
that both carry um a recessive gene and
they know for certain that a child has a
one in4 chance of having a dehab
life-threatening disease okay I think
there could be a moral argument for that
but saying that I want to customize my
child like I'm going to you know build a
teddy bear workshop I think that's
really sick I really do Tom or a
nefarious country just deciding they
want to build um a super race superum
that's
what can you give him that link about
China that they're building captain
americaas in China as of 2020 when we
found out that's a scary part they women
they I need F okay in 18 years from now
I need to have 5,000 super soldiers just
males order them up by by the way this
is it China has done human testing to
create biologically Clone War enh super
soldiers says top official US
intelligence agency did immediately
respond to request for comment about
whether China seeks super soldiers for
like those in such films as Captain
America they now have Gene editing to
build Captain America type soldiers in
China uh Adam for you thoughts on this
year Well never underestimate people's
ability to just have their own
self-interests basically endorsed so
people are going to do what the hell
ever they want to do couple things if
our enemy is doing it and making a super
race of humans we're going to kind of
have to meet them at their own game here
or we're going to get blown out of the
water I totally agree with Charlie where
like every year I go to the Special
Olympics my father had cerebral paly it
was a family thing we would go there he
had mentally he was 100% was good he was
sharp he did math like pbd physically
he' almost look he had a stroke but I
would go to the Special Olympics every
year and it was the most rewarding
empathetic like reality check where like
I'm a 15-year-old kid with pimples
they're like yeah you don't have it that
bad buddy these people have it
bad if you can change those people lives
people cereal cerebral poliy people with
major issues people with all sorts of
just autoimmune issues everything if you
can change that you're changing people's
lives I would be honest I'm be honest
Patrick I'm going to be very skeptical
about both the ethics and the execution
of this technology but if it can you
know help people from life-threatening
diseases you you know what it is when
you think about Gene editing there's a
handful of movies you think about you
got alium you got X-Men you got uh uh
fly you got uh Jurassic Park that's all
Gene editing so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here